1955 son père décide d'abandonner le
chant et le petit cerf cheville et
décide de le venger
lui il aura son nom écrit en gros sur la
façade de l'olympia 1965 ça commence à
marcher lorsque c'est l'accident
ils deux ans d'immobilisation mais lui
se remettra de son waterloo 1975 il est
le premier à oser et à bourg et le
palais des congrès 1985 c'est napoléon à
marigny deux ans à guichet fermé 1986 il
revient avec un album un album à femmes
bien sûr ouais si serge lama
oui
bonjour bonjour c'est toi c'est un jeu
alors serge lama 55 65 75 85 ans 95 tu
te vois comment j'aurais 53 ans mais
déjà c'est je sais pas j'ai pas d'idée
mais enfin je pense
j'étais toujours décidé que je ne serai
pas un vieux chanteur alors je pense que
je serai toujours artistes parce que
c'est la seule chose que je sais faire
mais peut-être que napoléon a été le
commencement d'ouverture vers a eu une
autre voie que qui est pas encore tout à
fait déterminé dans ma tête qui doit au
cinéma je me vois partout dans la ville
dans les possibilités que que j'aurais
parce que ce serait très prétentieux de
dire je me vois au cinéma parce que
c'est pas facile c'est un autre métier
mais enfin pourquoi pas
quand tu sais que scoop c'est un jeu sur
la presse puisque nos candidats tout en
l'air vont faire la une d'un magazine
qui s'appelle scoop
alors imagine que toi tu sois rédacteur
en chef d'un journal tu mettrais quoi en
ce moment aux couvertures si tu avais un
hebdo affaire actuellement avec tous les
problèmes internationaux je dirais
trafiquants d'armes qui trafiquent qui
avec qui comment qui vend des armes à
qui je crois que je t'aurais un petit
peu autour de ce problème qui finalement
est un problème très très actuelle est
très important donc tu ferais il est une
son trafic d'armes peut-être oui et dans
la section politique tu parlais de quoi
tu parlerais de la sphère libyenne tu
parlerais de la cohabitation du
parlerait de quoi je crois que la
cohabitation on en a beaucoup parlé
d'autant plus qu'elles n'existent pas
dans l'est dans la réalité en fait je
crois que la terre libyenne est beaucoup
plus grave sur le plan international que
que la cohabitation qui est quand même
un problème marginal et un problème de
deux pays quoi alors est-ce que tu
parlais de la religion bastille est une
chanson bien entendu qui fait un malheur
en ce moment c'est je vous salue marie
tu prends des positions qu'on peut
qualifier de d'intégristes et qui sont
pas très en ligne avec les dernières
positions du vatican sur la théologie de
la libération par exemple
c'est plus à droite que le pape pourrait
dire pas vraiment parce que le pape sy a
pas tellement longtemps
en tout cas pour ce qui concerne le
premier couplet de la chanson était
plutôt d'accord avec moi puis là il a
ramené à l'ordre certains prêtres calais
un petit peu trop loin dans le dans la
lèvre et la doctrine communiste et c'est
là la première partie de ma chanson est
ce que je constate au niveau des
soutanes c'est que le pape lui emporte
une en tout cas leur mec avec curieux
que le chef de l'église porte une
soutane et que ce qu'il représente un
pas vers le monde n'en portent plus très
bien alors est ce que dans la section
culture tu mettrais serge la main non
non moi je suis quelqu'un je suis pas
complètement idiot m'enfin je suis
quelqu'un qui chute et surtout là depuis
20 ans pour distraire les gens je le
pense que je les fais rire de temps en
temps je les fait rêver
de temps en temps je pense dire des
propos personnels qui sont pas forcément
ni très intelligent être bête on n'est
pas obligé de les partager
mais enfin je suppose qu'on appelle un
chanteur engagé il m'arrive bon comme
dans le cas de je vous salue marie
d'écrire une chanson polémique est une
chanson qui peut être considéré comme
engagé mais qu'ils ont ferrat est un
chanteur engagé
je ne vais pas partie de cette catégorie
là voilà très bien le chanteur de
variété populaire c